okay okay
so we're live using the camera audio
i think this h6 is dead i think the
batteries are done so this is completely
useless
but i'm here with captain wright
of right enterprises all right
enterprises
comedian extraordinaire
yeah 18 year old 15 year old
extraordinaire
uh i always [ __ ] that up 18 years old
or 18 year old
i think
like i would say i'm 18 years old but if
you're like describing someone like 18
year old yeah
like sometimes i say five foot eleven
and sometimes i say five feet eleven
yeah
not a grammar extraordinary seconds
um but yeah that's the ac goes off this
is just camera audio so i don't know how
good it's gonna be
yeah but we just did a weekend of shows
at uh madcaps comedy club
run by the eccentric adam
shout out to adam
and this is captain right
he killed all weekend
thank you everyone loved you it was fun
it was they're good crowds yeah
sometimes that place is just kind of hit
or miss
audience-wise
i mean it's a new smyrna beach yeah so
you get that
it's like a lot of old retired people
here yeah there's a lot of old retired
people that like
come from money
they're just like
displaying though yeah if they were
where they were from they wouldn't
survive because they'd be laughed out of
town for being old and weird yeah this
is like a
safe haven for all weird people yeah
it's the worst
yeah
yes we're on the beach sucks what was
your uh was your first like when you
first got here tomorrow was your first
impression
um
i thought that it was
like a typical everywhere in florida
looks the same yeah this is a typical
coastal florida town
large roads that destroy any sense of
community
uh little pockets
of humanity
um
just like yeah old retired people
you know people who are obsessed with
their superficial looks and stuff yeah
it's it's crazy there's just be someone
like see how much people spend on like a
truck down here like all in the city
it's like it's insane
yeah
i mean there's a large
a reward for being able to trick people
into thinking you're rich here
yeah because then you can get into their
inner circle and trick them to giving
you money
or if you're around money that it's just
like yeah it's bound to
it's just like it's just such a
different lifestyle i mean
and that's just the metropolis for that
here
yeah
so you're from orlando orlando's could
be different
uh but there's like parts of orlando
they're like the same type of community
yeah the rich areas
but like
the heart of orlando is way different
it's like all just you know younger
people
yeah a lot of hard driven stuff
yeah
so that's better yeah
it's more rich enriching like trying to
make a life for themselves
and then instead of just like
well that other guy lives life like this
and has all these things
put my house right next to his and do
the same exact thing
it seems like the
uh las vegas of florida
yeah it's everything's like the same
and it's just yeah that's what it seems
like
yeah they got all the amusement parks
there and stuff
but uh
yeah i mean
this is where all the old people come so
everyone's old people are all getting
trapped here yeah well you know about
the villages yeah yeah it's like
it's a completely different like vibe
full of people it's weird yeah like
they're they're like all like swinger
crazy people they weren't like partying
here they're all like
you should have nice table manners even
though i'm wearing flip-flops like that
type of
just snobby yeah they want to act like
nerds
you know nerds about being rich yeah
exactly even though like
a real
billionaire would be like what are you
doing people here really just tour here
for a while oh yeah for sure
and they each have their own like
strange community
yeah
yeah like north florida's different
panhandle is different from miami which
is different from
naples
yeah
florida should be three different states
so what do you think about governor ron
desantis wrong desantis it's a
i think he's a just like leaned into
crazy [ __ ]
i forget exactly what he was saying
but i think it was during the elections
when it was like trump has a right to
question
we've got to just go with what he's
asking us he's the president yeah
because i feel like
i don't think we're desantis did that
which is like smart
no yeah he didn't i feel like the
like what i meant about the sans is i
feel like he like he had his uh like
beliefs and ideologies and he like did
that but once people started like
you know obviously like disagreeing or
whatever like
getting on them you just double down
yeah
which uh
it's pretty amazing
yeah
he's just like
i don't care about your feelings yeah
but
attitude yeah because i don't know if
you saw there's like a thing i guess
like uh
it's like a year ago
when people were like still on the fence
about mass and he went to like
high school yeah the high school and
they had the mask on well you'd take
that off yeah you're being ridiculous
that was like peak and
shenanigans yeah
to a kid
yeah well i
i met him a little bit oh really yeah
the ufc in the green room he was like a
classic
classic politician he was like a
shuckster he's like a con man like hi
nice to meet you yeah you should move
down here
that was an exact thing but it was just
like really like over the top and like
i'm the alpha and it was a sort of like
uh
he has such a high voice where it's like
uh you can't really take him seriously
you're not really physically afraid of
him
yeah
it was just weird the level of like how
he he dealt with power and how he knew
he was a king boss and how he had to act
like that and how everyone wanted wanted
him to act like that
there's is all an act but he played his
part really well so that it worked but
everyone knows he's lying
it's such a weird
weird thing we're like letting him have
power
yeah
this whole thing is
suspect
yeah that's why i guess you you know you
have to do things like double down on
your act or whatever
and just be like
yeah it's all or nothing like we're
becoming totally stratified
yeah
yeah they have to go all in on the trump
thing or you have to hate america
exactly
there's no yeah which is like so
annoying
because then if you
you yourself are like a middle person
yeah both sides are gonna hate you
because like why don't you pick one
well yeah i don't think everyone should
be engaged in politics i think most
people should not be yeah if your whole
society is all about politics that's
like a circular loop like very pointless
society
there should be some people doing
different things yeah like people should
obviously care about things that are
important
but to be like
that's everything to me like i can't
live life
right without
that
but i mean i think like sometimes you
live in interesting times
and like you have your society asks of
you to do something
and you know
i think like
i think i don't think we're done yet i
don't think we're done cooking
like back in the day society asks you to
like go to the civil war or fight in
world war ii or [ __ ]
yeah
no for sure the standard constantly
changes
yeah
i mean it's frustrating when society is
limiting you
where it's like it's not a positive
thing to you
but uh yeah oh you do watch a lot of ufc
no i've only seen like a handful of them
but they're very fun to watch yeah i
just know the internet goes crazy over
uh patty yeah
that's really
cool that you know that because i think
he's like sort of
not that famous in the mainstream yet
but i guess you like are very in tune
with the internet because you're 18.
yeah
like i know like bar stool or whatever
like hyping them up or still sports yeah
awesome
you think he has this choke yeah that's
why he slammed in
that looks uncomfortable
yeah
oh
that looks tight
oh [ __ ]
oh
he's in trouble that's crazy
well i like it because it's so
viscerally entertaining like anyone can
enjoy it yeah
it's very it's very primal yeah it's
it's a
natural to watch
yeah because you see like a fighting
called like you're like i'm i gotta get
over there yeah i just want to see it
do you think we can put it up on the
stream or will we get taken down
um
i don't know i just would just come out
well
i got it recorded anyways yeah so like
like this
but there's no way to change yeah
um
yeah i mean
i don't know how legal this is
is my guy patty fighting the gay dude
tonight is he gay is he good yeah
he has a pretty good
deeds haircut
[ __ ]
youtube
yeah [ __ ] youtube
thanks for having us
um yeah don't you think it's weird
there's a monopoly on tech companies
yeah it's
it's crazy how they all just didn't
change because another one
has something
like twitter and snapchat and
instagram
i like how snapchat
or uh
this is snapchat
i think i guess the snapchat is like we
we absorb it into our
into our society
and it's like
snapchat existed and it still exists but
it it informs our society and we like
instagram and facebook more fit into
their thing and then now they have
stories and they have like seven like
those 15 second things that you can
watch that disappear in 24 hours if it
wasn't for snapchat it wouldn't have
happened yeah exactly
where like the um
just 60 seconds scroll
like uh oh like automatically yeah like
automatically
the short videos and [ __ ] yeah
and it just becomes another feature
yeah what we use on the big
companies oh my god
it seems like he's better on the ground
yeah
he's more creative
yeah he hasn't really thrown that much
yeah in terms of strikes yeah well this
guy i don't know who the grappler is
actually
i mean
like i would say patti pemblet is
definitely winning
so what is the internet saying about
patty pendlet
there's lava
it's just like uh
yeah
i think it's like mostly bars to sports
i go like look at this uh
this different guy
with the uh different hair
yeah
yeah it's just like any any type of
diversity as a character
yeah
yeah it's just like neurodivergence
people who are different
yeah it's like a
because they're probably like the
internet but the general interest is
probably so used to like seeing like a
big strong guys youtube ufc yeah another
guy that's like so like the autistic and
cells are like
i could be good at fighting too yeah
they're like that's might know that's
not like that's what i think like andrew
tates that kind of doesn't stop
why because he looks stupid not that
it's just cause like
wow he's so different
i idolize that because i can be
he's like a character of what some
people think they are because yeah
exactly
i mean it's highly unrealistic and a
product of a sick broken culture but
yeah
i don't doubt that a lot of people
identify with him
that makes a lot of sense oh for sure
who would like something like that
judging by what i have to deal with
yeah like someone act like that and then
they have been easy to get out too
because they're like oh no it's
it's a funny bit
but then they can just pull that off
well some people need a far higher
functioning they need to download and
just be whatever
they don't have they can't do the
independent thing which is fine like
some people are great at playing other
characters
and right now we don't have any
characters to play everyone is just sort
of like on their own
and the people that relied on that we
have a culture of like you know back in
the day everyone there's like five male
characters you get download and b's yeah
and now we don't have that
i hope uh
well the worst that'll happen is i'll
get a strike
so i get three of those okay it's cool
i think i should make it bigger
like zoom it in
at least like
well they've trained for this yeah
they're just doing this all day and the
more you do it the better you get at it
oh my god what has he gone in
is he trying to lift him
i think it's a choke because he's oh
shoulder on one side and then his arm is
on that i did not even see that one
coming he just slowly put it in like he
didn't even see it coming you know he
was very creative
he used that to get position i wonder if
he could have finished it from that
that is such a cool
thing
this is so frustrating
or you're just stuck there and you can't
get out yeah
this is so humiliating
oh
no
wow
he's wincing
his other hand is trapped
oh my god
that's so rude
i guess he did do it on purpose
wow
oh yeah there's a
he's just stepping on half times
this is the king of uh nicole or
whatever
the king of dustin's berry and he is
that's so like jesus yeah
he's such a goofy guy not like like he's
like sean o'malley except more he has
more humor yeah
the duchess of glaston shower
the o2 arena
where's that london i think oh wow
oh yeah
so would you rather be finished with a
submission or a knockout because a
submission is humiliating it takes like
minutes and you're dominated the whole
time yeah but a knockout it's like quick
and it's like oh it got knocked out it's
sort of like manly
i guess in a shape no i guess it's not
bad
but it's like over quickly but the
downside is that you're damaged like
you're hurting yeah
i i think i take submission
but look how sad he is yeah he looks
okay
you know just defeated completely his
other arm is trapped yeah
he's like he's fighting it with one arm
he has pelvis and his arm is trapped in
the same
cat
yeah
the [ __ ] body triangle so he can't
even breathe
yeah
that's crazy yeah
it's like a puzzle i'm trying to figure
out a puzzle
yeah the human body is a puzzle
yeah it's like how can i get this guy on
the ground and
yeah oh if i move this way he's gonna
move this side yeah
so let me move that way
that means he's exposing this front
let's see is that
this playbook
did you hear his interview with michael
bisping no no
michael bisman sort of makes fun of him
again
this is how i get down boy
obviously there was no talk before are
twerking and t-bags
[Applause]
is getting like strangled by a guy on
the floor
in tea bags
it's just a game dude
it was a tough first round but it was a
beautiful finish in the second round the
way you took the bike and the way you
trapped the arm with the one triangle
when we created is that something you
drilled in training
that's
once again
when you've walked out here the energy
[Applause]
i've never really been on it
yeah i just like like seeing funny
internet videos
and like a lot of their
original content must be like this is
[Applause]
is it good original content well a lot
of this is like podcasts and [ __ ] and
i'll upload like a podcast clip on their
instagram i'll be like
this is like
not funny or not like interesting at all
i usually go to reddit
to get fights
yeah sometimes i haven't been in one in
a while
but yeah
i'm pretty left-leaning
it's like doing a psa for mental health
so what do you think about this guy in
the internet
like the like him being hyped up by the
internet
yeah
i think it's good because it's like for
the right reasons you know it's like uh
like oh he's quirky who's also just like
a good fighter it's not because like
pushing some horrible morals or whatever
yeah
he's uh yeah he's not a horrible person
which is nice
yeah
because the internet like takes on a
horror one just to like
make him famous yeah like entertain
yeah like him clout or something
yeah he's an offering such a
well he is offering a very visceral
thing yeah it's a different thing like
you can't really build your melody off a
bit like you can
cope with tape
yeah no yeah people can
just be like mind controlled or this guy
is like oh he looks different
and he like you know he has a different
way than all the other fighters
yeah
yeah
it just proves that fighting isn't about
aggression or violence
or
unwarranted confidence i guess he has
that but it's not about like looking
good or anything it's just about the
task at hand it's not about anything
superficial that you can't control yeah
to a certain degree now you're just like
a genuine person
yeah
it's like he doesn't get better by being
fake he gets better just by being better
at being himself instead of some version
he's not trying to be luke rockholder
uh you know jon jones he's just like
getting good by being himself
yeah
[Music]
which i guess it's easy for people to
just like hop on that and like be like
yo
go check out this different guy
yeah instead of being like yo look at
this
crazy guy who's just like
you should own women or whatever
when a woman talks to you
you've got to slap them in the face
i think i love it because it's like it's
a it's a great bit yeah but then people
just don't like see that point they're
just like oh yeah i've never talked to
there is a version of that that you
should listen to but how much
like is it
yeah i don't know yeah i just can't
imagine ever consciously being that way
i can imagine if i happen to be that way
but if i make a choice to be that way
that's that means you're gone yeah
it's definitely like a
because he's definitely mastered because
other people will like interview him and
he'll be able to just
keep doubling down or keep like the
whole thing up yeah and just be like
like i think something like a woman
interviewed and wants me it's just like
basically putting that same thing he was
saying like videos just on to that
moment yeah well if you have a simple
thing it's easier to say the talking
points
you're like oh i know what i have to say
now yeah it might not be right like if
you don't have to be right or logical
yeah then it's so much easier to win
arguments because you can just be like
oh
this person is like saying that i don't
have to be logical i can just say
complete opposite
and get away with it
yeah at that point it's just like
annoying that person
that's how you win the audience
yeah
it's just about
getting them emotional yeah exactly
i saw a song hasanabi debate him
and i thought that
made him look so foolish
he's like you say that women can't drive
but all the data proves that women are
better drivers than men my personal
experience well that's when we have
science and that's how you we have every
technology is because we don't just rely
on personal experience but we like
collate data and stuff
yeah that's
a lot different than most people that
interview him because most people just
go like straight to being like because
it'll be like some like internet
celebrity that doesn't know anything
about anything yeah so the first thing
is they just get emotional yeah we start
looking
yeah it's hard not to because the guy is
just so
he's just saying what we think those
kind of guys that look like that are
thinking exactly yeah
but we're hoping that they don't because
like i
because i know he's like leaned into it
but i still think it's like a bit
because when you see him like interview
someone or like debate him he's like
sitting like this in front of a
microphone with like no shirt and
sunglasses on
like that's
you can't make that up
yeah
i think there's a version of that we
should be
and i think there's a version of that
that some women like
maybe not the smartest women but yeah
but it's just comforting to be like oh
this is like what i'm supposed to be
like my base level yeah like oh he's
he's the a man like he's like yeah
that's what they think he is because
that's what he says he's like i'm what a
man supposed to be
yeah getting knocked down kickboxing
fights
yeah
i think that
um
yeah i don't know what i was gonna say
i don't know i think
he's a pretty easy person to like
just kind of pick apart
and just get everything out of like this
is who that is yeah
i feel like a lot of people have a back
door in their head from religion
because we have like a lot of people
that grow up religious and
they need to be told what to do and once
the church isn't doing that we're
looking for
a new jesus
yeah
so i think it's really [ __ ] up how we
build the back door in people's heads
there's be able to be followers yeah
something so they don't have like
someone to just give feed them
ideologies yeah
just practice worshiping something
invisible so that you can be tricked
into believing anything then
yeah
it's like an exercise in compliance
which you know the internet is just made
like crazy
it's always like
because you see people with like
a quote them
their entire things like their merch
they'll like be like oh guys go to the
website i've got tickets for this
they'll immediately do that like it's
crazy you know like whatever ideology
they preach they'll preach too
i can say how easy it does now yeah
so the door is unlocked do you think
anyone's going to bust in
stasia
stage a thing
like a staying thing
yeah
new smyrna i don't know maybe it's
complete 50 50 time
this one is all over the place
no you know it's crazy that uh
they like a lack of police here
that's why a lot of people come here
spring break because they're like police
don't know what to do
there's so much like going
on so that's the reputation it's like
yeah it's like a party city
where like you don't have to like
go like bars or something you just have
fun
because the police are gonna try to stop
but they're not gonna be able to it's
not like a big city
that's too bad
well yeah i mean i think it's important
to have like people that enforce the law
overall oh yeah of course
like it's crazy to watch like a group of
like 500 teenagers
like one cop car trying to like organize
everything
which is like insane to watch
i was in uh panama city beach kind of a
beach city kind of a city beach i think
yeah just kind of western beach uh
city beach
okay yeah and we were just walking on
the sidewalk with a bunch of other high
schoolers going to the beach or
something and police crews cruiser just
like just piles into the middle of that
and then the cop goes out it's like what
what
and the kids are like man [ __ ] you or
you're like man what are you doing
they're all black
and he just like just drove into this
group of black people
and he started yelling at them and i was
like what the [ __ ] like why is the cop
doing this
no yeah yeah florida like anywhere
outside like central florida i'm sure
they're just like all right group of
black teenagers that's
trouble right there
it's such a pointless show of force oh
yeah
that's that's like when they i feel like
when they feel when they're not powered
they gotta like do all these eccentric
ways of just showing power
it's like oh you don't have any power
that's why you're doing it if you did
you want to do this yeah that's why i
like when i hate it when i go like to
cities like in their downtown if they
have like police on horses yeah what is
this what is this for yeah what are you
doing you just want to show that like
hey i'm on a big animal right now a
different way of doing things
the camera was on the whole time during
the battery
so yeah i mean
the horses are such a weird thing
such a weird symbol
yes
like it's so it's so pointless
because if you're like hey stop that i
need to get off a horse and like make
sure it doesn't run away yeah all your
power of human
stuff that you have to do eventually is
far away from you yeah literally
and it's
like controlling life to be like look i
can recruit life to help me in my quest
to
bring you down what do you think i'll do
with you
yeah i mean like
this is a
this is crazy we have horses i think
like we can do so much if we have horses
in that mindset but it's just
impractical
yeah
yeah unless you're fighting a pike
formation in the 14th century
yeah unless you're invading a castle
it's
pretty good yeah i mean it's good for a
crowd management they use it in england
a lot yeah
which i guess like you know you're
someone who's like been drinking all
night
you see a whole dangerous yeah horses
near trucks that's true because they're
going to try to head and kick some yeah
all that someone's going to get kicked
really hard yeah if someone's going to
just throw stuff at a horse and freak it
out but it hasn't happened yet
i think people are it puts fear in
people to where they have to get sober
up really quick yeah or they're just
like oh big animal
yeah
but the key to fighting cavalry is to
bunch up in a tight formation
and mess yourself up so you're not just
an individual getting hit by anyways
same things like if you see a bear you
keep yourself okay
but yeah the funnel the horses down
spear the horses yeah that's a good it's
like a good facebook group idea to be
like hey guys on saturday on 6th street
we're going to fight against the horses
we are finally standing up to the horse
overlords has nothing to do with the
police just horses you're gonna get the
horse police out the horses that trip
the police into riding them
yeah
i guess in other countries they'll do
that like elephants
that way yeah in a india yeah like india
or something i'm sure like the police
yeah those bigger police on a health
they're saying like crazy and practical
yeah the guy from an elephant
that'd be great
the thing is like during the protests in
egypt the 10-year square they would run
people over with tanks oh my god you
know it's crazy it takes you can't just
group up in a formation against the tank
yeah was that there like crowd controls
like hey there's a tank if you don't
yeah i go wet
it was like grand theft auto it's wild
it was horrible i saw the documentary
and there's
people that got their heads run over and
it's like oh he died but no it's like a
physical thing and you see a human head
with the tire track on it oh yeah
it's getting squeezed and it's like yeah
too faced
yeah it's like our heads just physical
isn't saying the stuff like that happens
yeah where's some of these crazy like
mass things like mass
craziness just like chaos somewhere
like any protest or something or
something happens
yeah
i love it yeah it's like it's super fun
to read about it like i couldn't be like
wow what if i was just like on the
street one day
i was just watching a protest with
people like run over
like you can never put yourself in like
that's gonna happen yeah
well the protests at the black lives
matter thing were crazy
yeah
like our country like lost its mind for
a second yeah it was wild like certain
cities were like just completely shut
down because
people were running wild but that's the
thing is like that's how we malfunction
that's like our way of rebelling yeah
it just inspired so much like you'll see
like i figured i think it was like los
angeles
the one where they like raided the
target and [ __ ]
and like half the city was on fire yeah
and like
in orlando that was really happening a
practical place because you have to
drive everywhere yeah there's no central
plaza where it's not like if there's not
already like a protest happening yeah
they can't have that mob mentality yeah
well i think like a lot of protests
were fine and the police were crazy in
them
like there were like looters and stuff
but there was also like police just
they were like we're not gonna learn
we're just we're gonna tell you this is
how we are yeah and they would like
funnel people in and gas them or beat
them with a baton or like some ladies
just walking home with their groceries
and she gets hit with a rubber bullet
people can fly and didn't stuff it's
definitely like the uh
everything started to happen so then
they're kind of pushed against the wall
and they had like a
right way they could have done it the
wrong way they just kind of went the
wrong way yeah and just overreacted a
protest because can you imagine being
like in minneapolis or like a [ __ ]
you know orlando and like you're hearing
all the internet what are you guys doing
oh [ __ ] you gotta give the police and
you're like
they're like a high school football team
yes like your big game or whatever yeah
it's a big game and you're just like
what was the worst way we could react to
this
yeah in chicago they just
waited it out they were like they're
going to lose we're not even going to do
our jobs
yeah they just let them they don't
really care
no that's a that's why they're with a
crime in san francisco though they don't
really punish people for like much of
anything
okay that's how like the carjacking
thing such a big problem oh yeah like
they're so laid back where it's like
there's no there's no middle there
yeah it's like people will get arrested
for carjacking and getting like a super
low
bail and like a little time let's go
right back to it
because it's like way is it
yeah
um
yeah i guess that's bad too
but uh yeah i think that uh
like the the looting and stuff is like
i mean
i'm surprised there isn't more
like the way that people are treated
yeah
like i would i would do it if i was like
in a shitty situation
i think it's like they just do like a
prompt like i don't think you have any
problem with it
yeah
it's hard to just start it yeah
it's like if one person is laughing in a
comedy club maybe one other person left
but if 20 people are laughing in the
comedy club and 40 people left
yeah
they're gonna be the first one you'd
never want to be the first guy to throw
a breakthrough and uh yeah
well that's why they were doing with the
umbrella man in minneapolis some guy
just came with a mask on and just
started breaking windows and they're
like this like some white guy they're
like who is this guy yeah
and they want things to go crazy so they
can be like look they're crazy we gotta
[ __ ] with them we gotta arrest them yeah
yeah i mean then there will be less
crying
yeah that's true
and just like focus on like
just like put being more focused on like
arresting people yeah you know we should
focus on like giving to the community
instead
yeah and like harass people when you
need to or whatever
yeah because then that's not a good
solution either just jail everyone doing
something wrong and you're just left
with everyone who follows the law yeah
it's like why well then then you can
just create a large people pledge not
like what if
a large amount of people just get
arrested and put in prison and then we
just have to feed them and stuff
like it's better to have productive
members of society than to
just jail everyone up and we should
focus on reducing crime
instead of like